hey
everybody hopefully this is not going to
be too
um yeah it's lagging again god damn it
this is just never going to stop doing
that i guess
uh hello there if you uh had noticed
this blank space over here yeah it's
just me today
um tom actually uh unexpectedly had to
go on a supplier out of stuff
and he was like you know i didn't even
really watch this movie
and i didn't care about it so you can
just do it by yourself if you want to
while i go out and get whatever the hell
he had to go to get sugar flour i don't
know what it was
um but yeah so i was like yeah that's
fine so i'm gonna say like right off the
bat this is probably gonna be
fairly brief because not because i
didn't like the movie because i did but
um you know it's i don't want to spoil
too much about it because it's new and i
also
just before i started recording got like
two very very large
graphic design jobs that are a rush so i
probably will have to work on those for
the rest of the afternoon
but i did want to drop in and talk to
you guys because i said i was going to
uh so this movie actually oh i was gonna
say too
movie retrospective for this week which
comes out on friday or thursday if
you're a patron
uh will also be just me because i just
recorded that like while he was gone
uh again it was a movie that i really
wanted to do but tom didn't really
dig it and wasn't into it so he's like
well you can do that by yourself too so
i was like okay just fine so i did that
by myself too
i'm not gonna say what movie it was if
you're a patron you already know because
i posted it on patreon
on saturday uh so some of you already
know
but yeah so this movie that
uh i'm doing today what ended up
happening with this one is that like i
said
we rent a lot of movies through the xbox
and this was what had been coming up in
the horror recommendations and we'd
watch the trailer
a couple of times like when we were
looking for a movie to rent we're like
you know that
looks pretty good you know maybe we'll
end up watching that one of these days i
think it was only like 2.99 or 3.99 to
rent it
and we just never got around to renting
it because you know either something
else like caught our attention or
whatever so we just didn't uh end up
watching it so then last night i was on
to be
um and i noticed that this movie
uh is free on 2b now which i thought was
very interesting so i was like oh well
we don't have to pay 3.99 to watch it
because now we can watch it
for free i didn't realize that 2b would
have
movies this new like they don't have a
[ __ ] ton
of movies from 2020 but they had enough
that i was just kind of like well [ __ ]
maybe i should start checking this
before i
go and pay to rent the [ __ ] you know
what i mean so yeah this is actually on
to be for free if you want to watch it
this is called the dark red now
this is a horror movie i would call it
more
it's kind of like a psychological
thriller mystery thing with like maybe
like some supernatural elements to it
and like i said i'm not gonna spoil it
but
i mean the trailer kind of goes into
like what you're in for now this was
directed by dan bush now that's the same
guy
that did the signal from 2008 which is
actually
which was actually very good it had been
recommended to me like a bunch of times
and i finally got around to seeing it
that might be on 2b2 i might have seen
it on there
um because i don't think i paid to rent
that either but um i think i liked the
signal better than this one
but this one is good too and the weird
thing about this movie is that
i liked it when i was watching it i
didn't love it it didn't blow my socks
off or anything but like the more i
thought about it
the more i liked it i don't know if that
makes any sense or not
but yeah so this movie um
the main character is named sybil
which i'm sure that's not an accident
played by april billingsly and she looks
really familiar and it was bugging me
and so i looked her up she's been in
some other [ __ ] too but the reason that
i recognized her was i guess she was on
the walking dead
she didn't have like a main part but i
think she was one of the people in
terminus like where the [ __ ]
whenever the hell season that was um you
know so it was a while back but i
recognized her anyway
so she's basically playing a woman
and at the outset she's in like
a mental hospital and this doctor is
talking to her
and she's clearly been through some [ __ ]
and
she seems to believe that
somebody stole her baby like she was
pregnant like eight months pregnant i
think she said
and that someone or some people
literally
cut her baby out of her stomach and took
him
now the interesting thing about this now
this is
like i said it's more psychological
horror it's not there's some gore in it
um but it's not like super over the top
cory
where where this comes from is that
you're not really sure because they go
like way into her background and like
she
obviously has some uh
mental issues and she has been diagnosed
with schizophrenia
so the whole like thing of the movie is
that is she
real is she crazy like did like did her
baby just die
and she's coming up with some crazy
story like to deal with it
or was there somebody that really stole
her baby so that's kind of what
you're getting at now i will say like i
said it starts out kind of cool it's
just like
two characters basically in a room just
like talking and she's kind of talking
about her past and then they talk about
a little bit about flashback like
her shitty childhood and her getting
adopted by some like after her mother
died and stuff
and then um so then they kind of go into
the flashbacks of her like meeting this
guy and i think at this point because i
think tom was watching it like to start
with
and then he like it was at this point i
think that he kind of tapped out because
it almost seemed like it was going down
i don't i don't want to say like a
lifetime movie route but it almost did
seem like it went too much into like a
love story type of thing like not in a
schmaltzy
kind of whatever but it did kind of go
into she meets this guy like her mom's
funeral
and um you know they're kind of talking
about how they got you know they got
together they got married and all this
other stuff but it does
it is relevant to the plot later on but
i can see how
if you're not there for it um that you
might get kind of bored and be like
what's the way like where the [ __ ] is
this going i can see
like so i can see that but if you stick
with it
it kind of goes in some really
interesting directions
because like i said it's sort of a thing
where you're not
entirely sure because like
it's like i hate to say because i don't
want to spoil it but it's like it could
go either way they leave like very
ambiguous
for a long time like weather cheese nuts
or whether all this [ __ ] that she's
describing like actually happened to her
and so i really kind of like movies like
that like where she could really have
female characters and they're
and they you know they have this like
crazy [ __ ] story
that i mean to be honest if somebody
came
to you with this story like she's saying
like you wouldn't know and would
probably believe it because it's
it's banana pants so you can cut
but the frustration of her like
trying to tell this doctor this story
because she wants to seem like normal
enough so she can get out of the
hospital and the doctor is like i'm not
going to let you out if i still think
that you're delusional or whatever
um because you know i know that your
story isn't true and blah blah so
there's like all this back and forth
there another thing about this
this gave me kind of um
scanners a little bit um
fire starter a little bit kind of vibe
um
i guess that's not saying cause like i
said it does have like a little
supernatural kind of thing
it really kind of i mean it's not as
overtly
paranormal or overtly supernatural as
those
and not as gory like i said it's kind of
a little more grounded even though there
is a little bit of supernatural [ __ ] in
it
but it gave me that kind of like
particularly that whole thing
you know in fire starter and in scanners
like with this shadowy
organization that's like trying to find
people that have powers and stuff it you
know what i mean it gave me like a vibe
like that a little bit
now like i said um it's kind of slow
it's not i don't even know if i would
call it a horror movie necessarily it's
definitely
much more on the psychological horror
end
with just a little sprinkling of
supernatural kind of stuff
um but that said i mean if that sounds
like
your cup of tea then
check it out by all means like i said i
don't think that i liked this one quite
as much
as the signal which was this guy's other
movie that i've seen he might have made
other movies in between there because
that seems like a really long time in
between but
um yeah but but that's the only other
one that
of his that i've seen and i've seen that
one just because i had a lot of people
like recommend it to me
so you know this one like i said it's on
you can rent it uh on xbox you can rent
it on youtube but
if you want to watch it for free uh it
is on
to be at the moment i don't know how
long it's going to be on there because i
know stuff kind of cycles on and off of
there
pretty quickly um so i would imagine if
it's new it probably will cycle off
there but
it's got like i don't know there's some
new [ __ ] on there too that kind of looks
good but i'm always kind of
worried about it because i don't really
want even though it's not
i mean you don't pay for them but i
don't want to like waste a bunch of time
like sifting through a bunch of movies
that are gonna suck because i've
tons of good [ __ ] i could be watching so
it's like i usually try to wait for
a recommendation like even if i don't
know like what the movie's about or
anything like that if somebody that i
trust
that has good taste in movies says hey
check this one out
um then i know what to look for this one
like i said i had seen the trailer a
long time ago and it looked
decent so it wasn't like you know i was
coming at it completely blind
but it did kind of go in a direction
that i wasn't expecting
which i thought was nice i did read some
other reviews of it it does seem to be
getting like pretty good reviews and
like i said i
this is another one that i think i might
wait like a few months and then watch it
again because
i i liked it while i was watching it but
then i think i liked it better
like the more i thought about it like
today like when i was thinking about it
like for doing this
show um you know i think i liked it
better
in hindsight if that makes any sense but
yeah so
um yeah be sis movies i'm watching that
show dark why is it always raining in
that show
well i think it's funny because like
what part of it you got to
like what season if you're on season
three yet but
the rain thing is kind of symbolic but
also
there's also a fog thing
in another um
thing that i you know like i said i
don't know if you got to season three
yet and if you know like what the big
spoiler is
because i know that i did the dark all
season three so i spoiled the [ __ ] out
of it and that but i don't know
like if you've watched it all the way
through or not but there's you know what
does means but it's funny because like
somebody else commented on another video
on
about dark that they're like man it
doesn't rain that much in germany like
ever
so i don't know what the [ __ ] but like i
said it's
there's a reason why you know what i
mean it's not super obvious reason but
it's a reason like if you think about it
um thomas carlisle said just uh
i started watching that movie spring
and um i need to go back and finish that
because i think i was watching it and
then like i got distracted by something
else sorry to do something else and i
don't think i ever finished it
um but yeah i definitely want to get
back to that because i think that's
still on shutter
too and yeah that's the same director as
the endless which uh
yeah i really liked that movie as well
so like i said the endless if you like
cosmic horror so yeah um
so like i said sorry this one's kind of
short but i've just
realized that i have like 40 million
hours of things that i have to do
uh but as i said i you know i said i was
going to come on and talk about this
movie today
so here i am talking about it um anyway
we will probably
do another matinee tomorrow or
sidetracks or whatever
i don't know if i can find any other new
movies tonight that i feel like watching
but if i can i'll come back and uh
review it tomorrow and
make tom come and do with me again too
i don't mind doing stuff without him
it's just i don't know
it's kind of it's kind of more fun even
when he's like cranky
about how much it was just like the
movies that i did today like i did this
movie
and um the movie that i did for the
retrospective on friday
um he was just not having it i mean
either movie he was just like
yeah i think he sat through like the
first maybe five or ten minutes
of the other movie of the old movie
and he was like um i'm gonna go play a
video game
you know i feel like he was just not
there for it so
uh like i get it i get it he's you know
he's not into
weird ass movies like i am and he just
doesn't really have any patience for it
which
i don't know it's kind of funny but um
this one i
this one i think he just because you
know he has that 10 minute roll and he's
like if i don't get into it in the first
10 minutes it's like i don't want to
watch it so i feel like he watched this
one like for the first few minutes and
then he just like wandered off
especially when it started looking like
it was going
like when she was talking about meeting
this guy and falling in love and
you know getting pregnant and all this
other stuff and he was just kind of like
yeah i'm out and
then he went over and played dune again
on his other like game machine or
whatever but yeah so
like i said i don't mind doing them by
myself but they are kind of more fun
when he's here that i can
bounce ideas off his head
but yeah so uh thanks you guys for
stopping by we will be
back again tomorrow talking about our
usual
[ __ ] like we usually talk about so
i'll see you tomorrow
bye